we will now go through a sequence of
examples that illustrate the different
types of questions that we usually
answer using a normal approximation
based on the central limit theorem in
general one uses these approximations to
make statements of this type that the
probability of the sum of n iid random
variables being less than a certain
number that this probability is
approximately equal to some other number
notice that this statement involves
three parameters a B and n and you can
imagine problems where you are given two
of these parameters and you're asked to
find the third and this gives us the
different variations of the questions
that we might be able to answer so we
will go through examples of each one of
these variations our setting will be as
follows we have a container and the
container receives packages each package
has a random weight which is an
independent random variable that's drawn
from an exponential distribution with a
parameter one-half and we load the
container with a hundred packages we
would like to calculate the probability
that the total weight of the hundred
packages exceeds 210 for example 210
might be the capacity of the container
since we will be using the central limit
theorem we will have to work with the
standardized version of SN in which we
subtract the mean of SN and divide by
the standard deviation of SN and to do
that we will need to know the mean and
the standard deviation now for an
exponential the mean is the inverse of
lambda and the standard deviation is
also the inverse of lambda and so we
know what these quantities are then the
next step is to take this event here and
rewrite it in a way that involves this
random variable
so what you would do is that we take the
original description of the event
subtract from both sides of this
inequality this number n times view in
this case n is a hundred mu is two so we
subtract two hundred divided by this
quantity square root of a hundred is ten
times Sigma this gives us 20 and we do
the same on the other side of the
inequality this is just an equivalent
representation of the original event but
what we have here is the probability
that this standardized version of SN is
larger than or equal to this number
which is 0.5 and at this point we can
use the central limit theorem
approximation to say that this
probability is approximately the same if
we use a standard normal
instead of Zn now for a standard normal
we can calculate probabilities in terms
of the CDF that's given in a table but
here we have the probability that Z is
larger than something not smaller than
something the CDF gives us the
probability that Z is less than
something this is easy to handle this
probability is 1 minus the probability
that Z is less than 0.5 which is 1 minus
the CDF of the standard normal evaluated
at 0.5 and at this point we look up the
normal table the standard normal table
and for n value for an argument of 0.5
the corresponding value is this one so
we obtain 1 minus 0.6 9 1 5 which
evaluates to zero point 308 5 and this
is the answer to this particular problem
in the next example we ask somewhat
different question we fix again the
number of packages to be a hundred
but we're given some probabilistic
tolerance we allow the packages their
total weight to exceed the capacity of
the container but we don't want that to
happen too often we want to have only 5%
probability of exceeding that capacity
how should we choose the capacity of the
container if we want to have this kind
of a specification so we proceed as
follows we want this number 0.05 to be
approximately equal to this probability
but now we take this event and rewrite
it in terms of the standardized random
variable that is we start from both
sides of the inequality and subtract n
times mu which is 200 and then divide by
the standard deviation of SN which is
this quantity and which is 20 exactly as
in the previous example and now this
random variable Z n is approximately a
standard normal so we're asking for the
probability that the standard normal is
larger than or equal to something which
using the argument as in the previous
example is 1 minus the CDF of the
standard normal evaluated at this
particular value now what this tells us
is that this quantity here the value of
the CDF should be equal to 1 minus 0.05
so this quantity here should be zero
point 95 what does this tell us about
the argument of the CDF we can look at
the table
and try to find somewhere an entry of
point 95 and we find it either here or
there we could choose either one or we
might decide to split the difference and
say that we get a value of point 95 when
the argument is 1.645 and so we conclude
that in order for this to be 0.9 to 5 we
need a minus 200 divided by 20 to be
equal to 1 point 6 4 5 and then we solve
for a and we find that a should be 232
0.9 and we can choose the capacity of
our container this way our next example
is a little more challenging here we
will fix a and B and we will ask for the
value of n here's the type of question
that has this flavor we are given the
capacity of our container we want to
have small probability of exceeding that
capacity how many packages should you
try to load what is the value of n for
which this relation will be true so we
proceed as usual by taking this event
and rewriting it in a way that involves
the standardized version of SN so we
need to subtract n times mu which in
this problem is 2 times n we subtract it
from both sides of the inequality and
then we divide by the square root of n
times Sigma which is 2 so we divide both
sides of the inequality by this number
once more this event here is identical
to the original event but now it is
expressed in terms of the standardized
version of SN this is a random variable
that's approximately a standard normal
so once more who are talking about the
probability that the standard normal
exceeds a certain value and by the
central limit theorem this is
approximately equal to one minus the
standard normal CDF evaluated at this
particular value here now we want this
quantity to be approximately equal to
0.05 which once more means that this
quantity should be point 95 and arguing
as before that we try to find naught
point 95 in the standard normal table
and this tells us that the argument of
the normal CDF should be equal to one
point six four five here we get an
equation for n unfortunately it is a
quadratic equation however we can solve
it and after you solve it numerically or
using a formula for the solution of
quadratic equations you find the value
of n that's somewhere between 89 and 90
now n is an integer so you could choose
either 89 or 90 if you want to be
conservative then you would set N to the
smaller value of the two and set n to be
89 our last example is going to be a
little different
here's what happens we start loading the
container and the container has a
capacity of 210 once we load the package
and we see that the way it has exceeded
200 and
and we stop let capital n be the number
of packages that have been loaded and
this number is random if you are unlucky
and you happen to get lots of heavy
packages then you will stop earlier we
would like to calculate approximately
the probability that the number of
packages that have been loaded is larger
than 100 now this problem feels a little
different the reason is that n is not
the sum of independent random variables
and so we do not have a version of the
central limit theorem that we could
apply to n what can we do well we try to
take this event and express it in terms
of the x i's and here's how we go about
it what does it mean that we loaded more
than 100 packages this means that at the
time that we were loading the hundreds
package we didn't stop and this means
that at that time after we loaded the
hundred package the weight had not
exceeded 210 so the event that we're
dealing with here is the same as the
event that the first hundred packages
have a total weight which is less than
or equal to 210 but now we're back into
a problem that we know how to solve and
the way to solve it is to take this
random variable standardize it this
actually is essentially the same
calculation as in our very first example
and we will get the standard normal CDF
evaluated at 210 minus the mean of this
random variable which is 200 divided by
the standard deviation of this random
variable which is 20 so we're looking at
Phi of 0.5 which we look up at the
standard normal table and has a value of
zero point six nine one five so this was
our last example and these four examples
that we worked through cover pretty much
all the types of problems that you might
encounter of course sometimes it might
not be entirely obvious what kind of
problem you are dealing with you may
have to do some translation from a
problem statement to bring it in the
form that we dealt with at this point
but once you bring into a form where you
can start to get close to applying the
central limit theorem then the steps are
pretty much routine as long as you carry
them out in a systematic and organized
manner